for four years Maspeth Zara has been
documenting life in indian-administered
Kashmir the photojournalist says she
joined the male-dominated field so that
she could give a voice to women and
children in conflict zones but mathuroth
says she was shocked when police used
what rights groups called a repressive
law and accused her of posting content
against the country to disturb law and
order these allegations are baseless I
don't have any political agenda I am NOT
any activist I don't have I am NOT any
social activist I don't have I'm not
affiliated with any political party
whatever I'm uploading are the reality
of Kashmir mathuroth is one of several
journalists the Indian government has
accused of carrying out what it calls
anti-national activities reporters
without borders has ranked India 142 out
of 180 countries in its annual Press
Freedom Index the monitoring body says
the score is heavily affected by the
situation in indian-administered Kashmir
with the government shut down
telecommunications for several months
after revoking the region's special
autonomous status that made it difficult
for journalists to report on what was
happening Kazi Shibley spent nine months
in jail after he reported on the
increase in soldiers there he was never
charged this gap you are a terrorist I'm
a patriot you are an anti-national I am
a nationalist the gaps that our
government and media have created how do
we remove those gaps the government says
it's open to criticism whether there are
limits to free speech we have only
issues the people who are making a
statement which is against the law of
the land against the country's interests
and those who are not safeguarding the
interests while making a statement or
somebody who needs to be made
accountable the editor of one of India's
few publications that is still critical
of the government says press freedom
must be protected so a constitutional
democracy for it to work it requires the
checks and balances of Institute
and the press and India today is in the
danger of failing to be a constitutional
democracy it may be a democracy in the
sense that the majority rules that the
mob rules in some senses but it is not a
constitutional democracy in the real
sense diligence
police are investigating the case
against math who says she won't stop
working despite facing up to seven years
in jail if convicted Reporters Without
Borders says India slipped to places on
us index because of constant Press
Freedom violations including police
violence against journalists it also
cited what it called coordinated hate
campaigns on social media against
journalists critical of the government's
Hindu nationalist ideology especially if
they're women
Elizabeth puranam al Jazeera New Delhi